parce qu'il y aura un retour à une vie
normale dr karl weiss président de
l'association des médecins des
microbiologistes infectiologues du
québec est avec nous dr weiss bonsoir
bonsoir à tous qu'est ce que vous pensez
néanmoins dû 1013 cas au québec c'est
quand même des bonds importants et on
parle de deux de transmission
communautaire maintenant c'est certain
qu'au québec et de transmission
communautaire il ya des éclosions qui
sont reliés des événements assez précis
où il ya eu des foules qui se sont
plaints gamme et donc c'est clair que là
on est dans la zone de transfert
l'infection d'une personne à l'autre à
l'intérieur de notre communauté
donc c'est ça des applications important
parce que maintenant on peut plus
considérer les voyages comme des
facteurs de risque ou des contacts avec
des voyages comme des facteurs de risque
donc la proche
on a d'un point de vue clinique dans la
vie tous les jours c'est que tout le
monde se présentent avec des symptômes
compatibles avec l'infection par le cos
vite 19 et potentiellement avoir une
approche
alors oui on est on rentre dans notre
zone si vous voulez chaude en ce qui
concerne l'épidémiologie et il va
falloir vraiment comme indigne c'est le
groupe
on respecte les consignes qui sont
données par le gouvernement on a
toujours il faut que les en garde ce
contexte c'est ce concept en est informé
de communiquer de coordonner de
combattre le virus et de l'éliminer
alors il faut que tout le monde met la
main à la pâte c'est vraiment le rôle
qu'on a quand titouan comme et puis
comme mais aussi et comme
professionnelle la santé est ce que vous
êtes rassurés quand on a réitéré en
conférence de presse aujourd'hui à
québec qu'on allait mieux protégés il
donnait des mots d'ordre parce que dans
des urgences
normal parce qu'on s'était dit on va
mieux protéger les gens qui sont dans
des hôpitaux à l'hôpital juif de
montréal et d'autres qui sont dédiés
qui vous recevront des cas de covin mais
il ya des gens qui se présente partout
êtes vous rassuré sur la protection du
membre du personnel
d'abord on doit jamais mieux protéger un
hôpital qu'un autre il faut protéger
tout le trou de la même façon et donc
que vous soyez à l'hôpital général juif
ou ailleurs il n'ya pas de différence
l'hôpital général juif on à nous décider
un moment donné d'augmenter nos mesures
de protection vue l'épidémiologie
convoyait qui était évidente devant nous
savez c'est comme une guerre où il ya un
aspect stratégique et un aspect tactique
et quand vous êtes dans un aspect
tactique il faut savoir comment vous
adapter au terrain
alors oui il faut protéger les
travailleurs de la santé c'est la clé du
système si on n'a pas de travailleurs de
la santé il y aura personne qui va
pouvoir donner des soins aux patients
et il faut là il faut comprendre que la
protection c'est pas juste des masques
c'est pas juste se laver les mains c'est
pas juste du triage c'est un ensemble de
mesures et c'est ça qui est important à
faire et à mettre ensemble mais est-ce
que c'est assez bien établie est ce que
le plan est clair sur le terrain il faut
que le plan soit clair sur le terrain
d'après je peux pas juger des autres
établissements
il est clair dans le mien parce que
celui là je le vois et je le vis tous
les jours et c'est sûr qu'il ya toujours
des petits attachement à faire ici et là
on ne fait rien du tout mais il faut que
le plan soit clair qu'il faut qu'on
protège les travailleurs de la santé de
porter des masques
lorsqu'on travaille dans une urgence
dans le contexte actuel c'est un masque
de toute façon vous avez juste à
regarder les images des gens qui nous
ont précédés dans les autres pays
puis j'ai contacté des gens dans
d'autres pays puis regardez comment les
gens sont préparés
comment ils vont si vous voulez faire
face dans les urgences à cette menace là
comment vous voyez les trois prochaines
semaines de pause au québec comment vous
voyez l'évolution de la courbe comment
vous voyez là justement l'armée lac est
en guerre contre l'ennemi est arrivé
alors là c'est sûr qu'on va voir on va
rentrer dans le nerf de la guerre
prochaines semaines c'est clair le nom
2k va continuer d'augmenter le nombre
d'hospitalisations va augmenter le
nombre de cas aux soins intensifs a
augmenté la question c'est de savoir de
combien ils vont augmenter est ce qu'on
va avoir les ressources pour faire face
à cette augmentation en préservant les
travailleurs de la santé parce qu'on
oublie les passionnés qui tombe malade
il faut les remplacer par quelqu'un
d'autre est aussi en fait en s'assurant
que la majorité des patients vont
pouvoir passer au travers et je vous
dirais que là pour les prochaines
semaines vont certainement et difficiles
mais déterminantes
c'est vraiment important que si les gens
se demandent qu'est ce que je peux faire
pour pouvoir améliorer la situation
qu'elle peut être ma contribution à ça
la contribution c'était faire exactement
ce qu'on vous dit c'est à dire ne pas
sortir de rester en confinement l'écouté
les mesures pour monsieur legault vous à
vous a donné c'est ça vous pouvez faire
mais êtes vous optimiste quant à la
capacité des hôpitaux de faire face à la
demande
je suis optimiste cependant la capacité
pour voir passer au travers de la
pandémie parce que c'est le même c'est
la raison de l'histoire on est passé à
travers toutes les pandémies dans
l'histoire donc il y en a près alors on
va passer au travers est-ce qu'on va
passer au travers comment la question on
l'avait on vous répondra dans trois
semaines mais il va y avoir des moments
difficiles c'est vraiment quelques
questions du public docteur va s
marie-paule primo vous demande pourquoi
certaines personnes développent des
complications sérieuses voire mortelle
alors que d'autres n'ont que des
symptômes légers
alors c'est difficile de dire moi je
pense que définitivement une cause
génétique à ça parce que vous avez juste
à regarder ce qui se passe
oui que dans le sud de l'europe en
méditerranée donc en espagne en italie
vous avez beaucoup de cas avec beaucoup
deux cas sévères et beaucoup de
mortalité c'est pas parce que les mots
les hôpitaux italiens ou espagnols sont
mauvais ou au contraire certains sont
même très bon vous avez la france qui
est un pays avec va dire une espèce de
bassin génétique un petit peu différent
donc un bassin plus mélangée qui est un
peu entre les deux et vous avez l'europe
du nord vous avez aussi beaucoup de cas
avec beaucoup moins de mortalité donc
est ce qu'il ya une explication
génétique nous ferait que vous allez
avoir une différence entre l'europe du
nord et l'europe du sud vous savez qu'en
chine a déjà dit qu'il y avait peut-être
des associations entre la sévérité
certains groupes sanguins donc là
retrouver la raison pour laquelle
pourquoi certains groupes sont
probablement génétiquement prédisposés à
faire ou maladie plus sévère que
d'autres c'est intéressant
c'est intéressant julie montplaisir vous
demande je suis en congé de maternité
mon conjoint travaille pour un service
essentiel
yat-il davantage de précautions à
prendre pour protéger les très jeunes
bébés non pas vraiment je vous dirais il
n'y a pas eu de notions que les très
jeunes bébés sont vraiment plus à risque